is a toxic podcast what's toxicity
okay let me tell you something yeah I
came from a marriage right and I had to
separate from my partner for a part wow
like say why you separated them from she
separated from her husband because he
might cheat not because he cheated
because he might cheat and the longer
the conversation went on the more she
changed it and now she's on this podcast
she's changing it again separate right
and I said for the sake of my child
we're trying to co-parent and heal our
relationship hold up are you on the show
yeah now now let me land let me learn I
said because of situations
[Laughter]
see now she's made herself look like an
idiot because they didn't realize who
she was until now she's mentioned it the
guys on the left are like oh yes I
remember this clip
slightly contradictory
that was me coming in yeah what I'm
saying is me saying that and I've said
I've gone through my trials and
tribulations right and I didn't realize
how hard marriage or whatever was and
plus the Western culture influenced me
in a certain and this is a culture yeah
this is this is what modern women do
like they they want to paint the story
in the way that they're like even when
they it's weird even when they take
accountability they like don't they'll
be like oh well it was the culture that
influenced me and I Did It For My Child
because it's what's best for my child
and it's just like no but the boyfriend
is you were a selfish modern woman that
put yourself before your kid she's
talking about her culture this is a
woman that grew up in a was it 16
children because there has been a dad
had two wives so I think there was like
14 or 16 children but yet she's talking
about her culture and going on social
media I'm trying to unlearn that and I'm
trying to go back to what I want to be a
feminine
[Music]
woman right so I said whatever I'm doing
I'm going she then told me that I left
my relationship I've she said that she
said that she left because her husband
might cheat we didn't say it she did in
my child's life and I'm going to further
ruin my child's life
because we were talking about the
statistics of bringing up a child in a
single parent home I even asked her is
it cheaper to live together or to live
apart she said it's cheaper if we live
together I said well if you've got a
three-bedroom house and you're going to
live separately why can't you take one
room your husband take one room and give
your child the other room and at least
make it look a bit better also she said
she didn't she did she not to them now
that she actually went out looking for
looking for men she actually said that
on the on the podcast that she actually
went out there on dating apps and she
wanted to try day in and see if she's
gonna move on but yet still she was
waiting for her husband waiting like I
think she was giving herself a break of
three years and I think somebody says
that when when a woman says that she
wants to break a free year she just
wants to go go and um and see what's
happening in the streets well and the
other thing is like
she volunteers all this information we
don't have to go back to ever because
she got she doesn't watch the podcast
and you see Pearl said to her why are
you why are you giving us all this
information it's like based on what you
said and then we comment on it yeah and
it's like all we do all I do is hold up
the mirror yeah and and if your husband
doesn't want to be with you it's like
why why and and that means you have to
work on something and it it to get back
to that spot and that's what and you
probably want to tell her to do not have
a break for three years how can you say
I've got to go and find myself and and
he's got to go and find himself and
that's why we said that she seem to got
everything backwards because she got
married then she had a child now she
wants to go and find herself how can you
find yourself when you're apart from
your husband you're working on you
you're working on him and then she said
oh if we get back together in the end
it's like oh we you can't be saying you
want to get back together because you've
been out there looking and the only
reason when you're going to get back
together because
that's why you're going to decide that
you want to go back otherwise you'd be
working on your marriage you wouldn't be
working on yourself you need to work how
can you work separately and then come
together you're going to be two
different people still well and then the
other thing she would talk about and
again guys the only reason I commented
on this is because she volunteered all
this information there was like four
other girls in the room who didn't talk
and and the thing is she would talk
about how she's going to live as a
feminine woman and I kept asking her
like what did you do to be feminine and
she kept giving me these broad answers
that didn't make sense like like a real
answer would be
um that I don't know I learned I learned
to cook like a bunch of different
recipes yeah um I'm actually you know
I've invited my husband like if I wanted
to get back with my husband like I I
cook him dinner on Fridays yeah and
appall and truly apologize for working
her way towards him again right but she
would just give me these broad ass
answers and the thing is that would
contradict everything she said because
if you're doing this what feminine women
aren't freaking on dating apps and that
Carnival but when she first spoke for
about I don't know it's half an hour an
hour she didn't mention that she had a
child because I remember when she
mentioned the child I was the first one
to say well hang on a minute it's
different now because you've now got a
child you know that makes it even more
reason to try and make it work for the
marriage because you have a child but
she spent so long being selfish thinking
about herself talking talking about
herself what she wants or what she wants
to go on dates and she's going to do
this she's going to do that and then all
of a sudden up Pops his child out of
nowhere and we were all surprised that
she actually had a child because as a
mother you mentioned your child
especially if you're a child's at
Primary School the child's young enough
you can't come and sleep you mentioned
your husband you mentioned that the ABS
you mentioned everything and then
eventually it slips out that I have a
child and everybody's view changed after
she and she couldn't handle it and then
and then she talked about yeah I'm now a
traditional woman and I would just be
like okay I'm sorry you cannot be a baby
mama because I you cannot be I'm sorry
you can't be a baby mama that's at
carnival and I'm just I'm just reading
back what you
volunteered who left her husband because
he might she or maybe she said it was no
she kind of she doesn't she said my I
always remember that she said my no I
said yeah I started by saying that he
said like that because I think at first
she kind of made it seem like she left
and then later when she started to look
bad she like switched it yeah and that
was the whole point was like and I don't
God only knows I don't really care
because she even said that because her
dad had another word had two wives that
if her husband turned around and said
you know I want two wives she could have
worked with that or even thought about
it but what he actually says is that you
know she said oh would you do this and
he said well you know it turns out that
he might so she left her husband because
he might but yet she contradicted
herself and said that if he said he
wanted another wife like her dad she
would have thought about it because that
is not off the radar for her have being
a second wife like you and Jess going
off statistics though I don't care
they don't care about statistics because
I understand statistics you need
anything
before everyone speaks guys we're all
content creators
and he's talking to you two in the
middle and he's talking to you two in
the middle and this is the thing on that
podcast I remember ending it and
thinking I barely freaking talked yeah
because this girl and and this is one of
my weaknesses as a host is reigning in
these crazy guests that's why I need to
join you sometimes I know I know we
should do like Wednesdays or something
yeah let us know let us know in the
comments what day yeah
let me let me finish yeah with the
statistics I don't care what statistics
she wants to put me in I'm not a single
mom who's got no education I've got a
full Masters right I've got a full no
one cares that doesn't mean you can
raise a better child and what I what I
went off of was the fact that you you
said you were at carnival you you said
that you're a single like you always all
the information you volunteered there's
like three other girls on the podcast
there was another single mother she
didn't volunteer any of this information
about her baby daddy and you know it's
not feminine going around telling your
business on a podcast yeah that so if
you're living as a feminine woman and
you're chatting all this [ __ ] about your
baby daddy like does that that's not
what feminine women do Africa hardly
said anything and also there was a girl
on there that said that she don't care
what she says that as she goes to
Carnival as a single woman she's looking
man the mother was a girl that said that
because a girl said to her no I don't
believe you if I'm going kind of as a
single woman I know what I'm going for
I'm going to look for a man and oh no oh
no bloody degree in politics as well
international relations right I did my
thing I've got my whole career and I
went into her marriage I had my child
things didn't work out I'm not a
statistic my child is yes you are you're
a statistic come on you're a statistic
they're telling you you are a statistic
you've made yours she could have been a
statistic of you know happily married
women with you know nice family with a
child that is a statistic that is a good
one she don't want to be the single
parent statistic but that's what she's
made herself and if you don't want to be
it don't be it go back figure it out
like get on your knees and beg beg say
you'll do whatever it takes to bring the
family back together she didn't say we
wouldn't have known no I know and like
if someone told me okay because I'm
trying I put myself in her shoes you're
a statistic you're between like you're
one of the women between the ages of 25
and 45 that's single I would say yeah
and I'm trying to work on it but she
didn't say it like yeah I'm trying to
work on it she's like in denial oh oh
starting wife school go subscribe yeah
kids you can meet right and all single
parents say that that's that's what
they're about to see yeah does not ever
go without my child will never also go
with that so you can't say that I've
just but she goes without her dad half
the week or her mother you can't say she
never goes without and I think that came
up when you said that you that your dad
was early then you'd rather your dad was
there she said her dad was only over
there but her dad was hardly ever there
because he had two women to service
right and all these children but and the
difference is your dad was at work so
his bed was in the house he didn't sleep
anywhere else he came in the house and
that's what I was saying to her that
even if they moved in with the husband I
mean she's living somewhere else and
he's got a three-bedroom house how does
that make sense well and and even with
my dad like there is still there's
something about knowing your dad's
coming home yeah even even if it's super
late or even if he's out of town for a
week like there's something about like
you're waiting for your dad to come home
or you're like a little mini Christmas
yeah yeah yeah and it's like
you're you are a statistic and you can
try to deny it all you want but you look
delusional and that's not my fault all I
do is hold up a mirror to what you said
get mad people might separate people
might have children in different
circumstances because they're now single
doesn't mean they're ruining their
child's life because it might be you're
not single that's the whole point you're
still married benefit that you're not
single you're married alone mother two
parents have to separate that's not what
people are saying we're saying that
holistically and I love Eddie he's
always the man of reason at least
speaking that when a child is taken out
of a two-parent home you don't put them
in every statistical disadvantage of
that kid which is what Pearl said
um that's not to say that you're not a
good mother or you can't raise your
child properly that's just saying that
most women in your situation end up in
situations where the kid goals and
that's fine
you can say most women you see see the
guy who left he's like which is why you
fit into this house she don't want to
say and do you and do you let him talk
no did you cut him off again please
but then is she gonna land then we're
generalizing you though in it you're
asking us you're saying no you don't
want to be in it but then I'm putting
you in a category
my girl let him talk out of there no I'm
not saying that my child's Dynamics
especially me and her father my child
doesn't know that we've separated she
doesn't see that we're not together
right and I say this because when he
does come he'll come we'll do things as
a he never mentioned any of them she
never mentioned anything about the dad
doing anything together and picking him
up and him having her one day and she
never know the other day she never said
anything yeah kids aren't stupid
and this is the thing this is the thing
okay the truth comes out eventually and
I swear to God I believe this with my
heart and my soul one day your kids will
grow up and they will talk and how will
they talk about you your kids will grow
up and they will talk and especially in
this day and age they're they're
probably gonna have their own podcast
about you if you [ __ ] them up they
will watch this what are we talking
about the kid knows that their parent
that his parents are not like everybody
is his friend's parents and maybe I mean
who knows maybe the kid's too young and
I don't know how old the kid was
my granddaughter came home and spoke to
her parents and she was absolutely
disgusted that they weren't married she
said to her dad why didn't you marry my
mum my friend's mum and dad are married
what do you mean you're not married you
take me to school dad do you bring me
home you're supposed to start she was
really annoyed and she's trying to say
that kids that notice at five and my
granddaughter was absolutely fuming why
won't you marry my mum what's wrong with
my mum why wouldn't you marry my mum and
her mom said I want your dad I think you
should marry my mum I can't believe that
you're not married but your mummy and
your daddy you're supposed to be married
and she reckons he's not gonna find out
he'll go to work I'll say he's gone to
work or I'm working and he has her right
does he live there no he doesn't live
there but we live 10 minutes away from
each other now it's 10 minutes away she
never mentioned a distance she never
mentioned she just said they lived
separately and 10 minutes out 10 minutes
walk 10 minutes drive 10 minutes by the
plane she's still trying to land yeah
but she won't probably won't notice now
but she's gone and when she notices
hopefully we might be and this is what I
said on the podcast we might be in a
situation where it might work out right
no she never she says she's giving it
three years which means that her
daughter will be eight which means that
her daughter had already known that her
mum effed up her life already so you
can't say that oh we're gonna work
things out and then we're going to move
in together and the girl ain't gonna
realize that eight years old she will
know if you if you really like I'm just
like I'm trying to put myself in her
shoes right so if I was with a guy and
maybe there was something that I did
like maybe maybe I was too jealous or I
was too something like to the point
um that he left and it was something
that I genuinely did like I swear to God
I'd be breaking my back like like it and
she's overweight men value you being in
shape yeah so so like I swear to God if
my ex-husband and I and I and I
genuinely wanted him back it like I
genuinely felt like that was the best
thing for my kid and like I don't know
what she's doing I don't know what she's
not doing maybe maybe she's doing some
of these things but if she was a show
but it's not showing because she's not
doing it yeah okay I can say it she's
not he's not doing she's not doing it
it's I'd be I'd be in the gym okay first
of all I'd be I'd be trying to look so
good this is you know what this is game
this is game if you want to get your
husband back this is what I would
recommend I'm not saying as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible